Transcriber: Ayat Alasadi
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
أغلب الناس يستخدمون كاميرات تليفوناتهم او
كاميرات احترافية لتصوير
نشاطات حياتهم المختلفة
طبعا اغلبكم احتمال تعرفون
ان عملية التصوير هذه هي
تخليد للحاضر و قد تكون سجل للتاريخ
بالمستقبل
مثل ما نشوف هنا بعض الدول صارت تستخدم
التقنيات الحديثة مثل التصوير المحيطي
لتسجيل هذه النشاطات
طبعا حتى الناس مثلا بالمستقبل
بامكاننا رؤية  عاداتهم و تقاليدهم
او رؤية  مثلا تتعلم منهم دروس
او تتعظ او حتى تتفاخر بهم
هنا أنا فكرت أن كيف
نقدر نستخدم
هذه التقنيات حتى نعيد بناء .
طبعا قبل هذا كله عملية التسجيل
هذه ليست جديدة
هذه ترجع إلى آلاف السنين وبالتحديد
من العراق من ارض الرافدين
لما أجدادنا كانوا يسجلون
أماكنهم و طرق حياتهم على الألواح الطينية
لكن  هناك جزئية ناقصة بالتدوين .
لأن نحن لانستطيع تدوين كل شيء
لهذا السبب استخدمنا التقنيات
الحديثة وكان يوجد لدينا
مصادر مثلا
الألواح الطينية هذه التي وجدوها على جدار
حائط قصر سنحاريب
نينوى
فسرتها الدكتورة
ستيفان دالي عن طرق الري وأشكال الأشجار
التي كانت موجودة ذاك الوقت .
طبعا بعض الناس تتسائل لماذا نتكلم عن
الجنائن التي تعتبر قديمة
ف لنشاهد هنا  نماذج من الدول مثل
إيطاليا التي بشكل دوري ومستمر تنصب
الدعامات ل برج بيزا المائل
حتى تمنعه من السقوط .
كذلك فرنسا تصرف مبالغ طائلة لإعادة بناء
وترميم كاتدرائية نوتردام التي أصابها
الحريق .
هنا قررت استخدم التكنولوجيا الحديثة
لإعادة بناء الجنان المعلقة التي دمرتها
العوامل البيئية ، حسب ما يقال أنه زلزال
استخدامنا الواقع الافتراضي لهذا الغرض .
قبل أن نرى الجنائن المعلقة بالواقع
الافتراضي
لابد من اعطاء فكرة عن الواقع الافتراضي
الواقع الافتراضي هي عملية صناعة بيئة
أما عن طريق تصوير محيطي
يعني المدينة أصلا موجودة ، أو عن
طريق تصميم هذه المنطقة بالكمبيوتر جرافيكس
بالتصميم ثلاثي الأبعاد بعد ذلك تحميلها
على أجهزة الواقع الافتراضي ، كأنما انت
موجود في هذا المكان بالفعل
كتطبيقات سوف اذكرهن  وبشكل سريع
عن استخدامات الواقع الافتراضي .
مثلا نقدر نستخدم بالعمليات الطبية تدريب
على العمليات الطبية بالواقع الافتراضي قبل
التطبيق الحقيقي .
كذلك ممكن  يستخدم ك علاج للمرضى
الاشخاص المصابين ،
الاشخاص  المصابين بالتوحد  يقدرون يستخدمون
الواقع الافتراضي للعلاج .
كذلك بالتعليم بالمدارس
طلاب المدارس الصغار خصوصا دروس
الفيزياء والكيمياء ،
ب استطاعتهم تعلم التطبيق العملي أفضل بكثير
من مجرد قراءة النصوص أو مشاهدة الصور
عن التفاعلات الكيميائية مثلا .
كذلك تدريب الجيش  ب استطاعتك ان  تتعلم
استخدام الأسلحة وصيانتها .
تتخيل نفسك في أرض المعركة بالواقع
الافتراضي
بعد ما طُبق بالواقع ، وكذلك استخداماتها في
مجال الرياضة .
هذا مثال على الرياضة مثلا تقدر تستخدم
الواقع الافتراضي للتدريب على السياقة بشكل
عام أو على سباق السيارات .
كل النقاط هذه التي ذكرتها التي يساهم
او يساعد بها الواقع الافتراضي
أنه يوفر بيئة آمنة لكل هذه التجارب
في نقطة تشترك بها .
تقليل موارد الصرف
وكذلك سرعة بالإنجاز .
هنا جمعت فريق صغير من المصممين العراقيين ،
وقدرنا نبحث عن أي مصدر يساعدنا بإنشاء
الجنائن مثلما كانت من قبل .
استطعنا رؤية  شكلها بشكل تقريبي .
كذلك الألوان التي كانت بها، يعني شغلنا كان
غير عشوائي وإنما مستند على بحث ،لأن من حسن
الحظ
عمتي تملك دكتوراة في التاريخ هي التي
وفرت لي هذه المصادر كلها
مثلما تلاحظون أن هذه نتيجة شبه
نهائية ومقارنتها ب اللوح الطيني .
وهذه أيضا .
مثلما ترون أننا قدرنا نوصل الى شكل شبه
تقريبي
للجنائن مثلما كانت قبل آلاف السنين .
هنا يستطيع أي شخص من الجمهور
ان يجرب الواقع الافتراضي لأول مرة .
أي شخص ؟
(مساعدة شخص للتجربة ) : اعطني يدك .
الشخص الاخر : لايوجد داعي
ضع رجلك على الدرج
ضع  قدمك على الدرجة الاولى ثم الثانية
الثالثة ثم الاخيرة
الان انت رسمياً تتمشي في الجنائن المعلقة
مثلما كانت قبل
تستطيع الان رؤية الاشياء المحيطة بك
تستطيع التحرك تستطيع الدوران
- هل يوجد ارض ل امشي عليها ؟
نعم ، تقدم للامام قليلا
انا سوف اساعدك
انظر للتماثيل امامك .
أي شخص يحب  يجرب ؟
انتبه  .
لا .
بالطبع الفيديو هذا هو فيديو
محيطي للجنائن المعلقة .
عندما صممناه لم نصممه اعتمادا على
شكل فيديو اعتيادي
يعني انت تستطيع تتخيل نفسك
كأنما موجود
في هذا المكان .
الجهاز سوف يفهم مكانك بالضبط اين
وسوف يحاكي حركة الفديو
فعندما ترتدي جهاز العالم الافتراضي ،
دماغك سوف يرى أنه بهذا المكان
المكان سوف يتخيل أنه بالفعل موجود في هذا
المكان وبهذه الطريقة ، استطعا أن نعيد ولو
جزء بسيط من تاريخ العراق .
هذا مشروع صغير من عدة مشاريع
قادمة إن شاء الله .
جميع آثار العراق الموجودة الموجودة حاليا
ونطورها والتي ليس موجودة أصلا مثل
الجنائن المعلقة
سوف نرجعها بالعالم الافتراضي نتأمل
بالمستقبل  من الممكن ان تنبني في الواقع .
مثل ما تلاحظون هنا بالعراق ، الحياة طبيعية
مثل بقية الدول ،
الناس يمارسون حياتهم بشكل طبيعي .
لكن توجد عبارة دائما تتردد على بالي،
أن العراق هو البلد الوحيد الذي
ماضيه أحلى من حاضره .
نحن لن نتطور ... ، اريد ان  تفكروا للحظة
أن العراق لو كان بمثابة والدك
و الد خالد لايموت
والدك دائماً كان قوي و قام بتوفير كل أمور
الحياة التي تحتاجها حتى تعيش .
لكن و الدك مَرض بعد فترة من الزمن ،
ف ماذا ستفعل انت ؟
هل سوف تترك والدك و تبحث عن والد اخر ؟
أو تفعل كل مايلزم وتفكر بإيجابية
حتى يرجع مثل ما كان قبل وأحسن .
شكرا جزيلا .